Who is Aquaman?
If you've seen Justice League, you know him
as the ludicrously muscular Jason Momoa.
If you grew up watching Superfriends, you
remember him as the blond guy in an orange
shirt who didn't usually have much to do.
If you've encountered internet humor in the
past 20 years, you've probably heard that
he talks to fish.
That's not all, though.
He's been a king, a husband, a father, an
amputee, and an exile in his decades-long
existence.
So, he's a pretty busy fish-guy.
Here is the untold truth of Aquaman.
"I'll try to make this as quick and painless
as possible"
Alternate origins
Everybody knows that Aquaman's from Atlantis,
but in his first appearance in 1941's More
Fun Comics #73, that wasn't the case at all.
His father was a world-famous undersea explorer
and researcher.
Aquaman's mother died when he was a baby,
and his father took him to live under the
sea.
Using the ancient science of that forgotten
civilization, he raised Aquaman to live comfortably
under the sea, giving him the ability to breathe
water and the name "Aquaman."
It was only later stories that made Aquaman
an Atlantean prince.
In the 1940s he was simply too busy fighting
Nazi U-boat captains to have that complex
a backstory.
Alternate alternate origins
Adventure Comics #260 established that Aquaman
was the son of a lighthouse keeper named Tom
Curry and a mysterious woman who came from
the sea.
On her deathbed, she revealed herself as an
exile from Atlantis, and that their son Arthur
had inherited her aquatic powers.
Later stories would establish the mysterious
woman as the Princess of Atlantis, making
Arthur Curry the heir to its throne.
In 1989's Aquaman Special #1, this origin
was revised yet again so that Aquaman was
born in Atlantis, left to die in the open
ocean as an infant, and later adopted by the
lighthouse keeper.
Arthur being raised by a lighthouse keeper
has remained one of the more consistent details
of Aquaman's origin stories going back to
the beginning, even when later retcons would
add in a biological father who was an undersea
wizard and other familial weirdness.
Aquaman and his octo-pal
Most people remember Aquaman's sidekick as
Aqualad, a dark-haired teen in red and blue.
"Aquaman!
With his teenage ally Aqualad, guards and
defends all that lives in the sea against
the forces of evil."
Aqualad first appeared in 1960, but Aquaman
met his first lasting ally years earlier,
in 1956.
In Adventure Comics #229, Aquaman is inspired
by a Canadian Mountie's relationship with
his horse, so he holds a contest to see which
sea creature should become his sidekick.
The winner ends up being an octopus named
Topo.
Since Aquaman's solo adventures pretty much
all take place at sea, an octopus has more
to contribute than you might expect.
Even after Aqualad came on the scene in Adventure
Comics #269, that clever octopus has stuck
around as a member of the supporting cast.
Aquaman uncovered
You've almost certainly seen the cover to
The Brave and the Bold #28, the first appearance
of the Justice League of America.
Now here's what you might not know: that first
Justice League cover where they're fighting
Starro is the first time Aquaman ever appeared
on a comic book cover.
Sure, Aquaman had been around for nineteen
years, but he'd never had his own comic.
Superboy had been the cover feature on Adventure
Comics for as long as he and Aquaman had been
featured in the book.
Before that, Aquaman was overshadowed by Green
Arrow in the pages of More Fun Comics.
Being a minor hero whose adventures were mostly
at sea, Aquaman had never joined the Justice
Society of America, DC's first superteam.
By the time that team was revamped with a
new name, however, Aquaman had survived for
so long that his veteran status made him a
shoe-in for the new team.
Making him an active part of the DC Universe
increased his popularity to the degree that
he finally got his own solo comic starting
in 1962.
Aqua-married
Having his own title in the 1960's gave Aquaman
more room to build a complete supporting cast,
including an ongoing love interest, something
he'd never had before.
Mera was introduced in Aquaman #11 as a beautiful
queen from another dimension with the ability
to control water.
In issue 18, Aquaman finally takes the throne
of Atlantis, but learns that he must immediately
choose a queen, so he and Mera get married
in that same issue.
Superhero weddings were largely unheard-of
when this happened in 1964.
The most famous superhero wedding of the 1960s
was Mr. Fantastic and the Invisible Girl tying
the knot in Fantastic Four, but that didn't
happen until 1965, a year after the big Aqua-wedding.
Aquaman established the tropes that would
turn up again in Fantastic Four and other
wedding stories, like costumed guest stars
as guests and of course supervillain attacks.
Baby on board
Once Aquaman and Queen Mera were married,
it was only a matter of time before they produced
an heir.
Arthur Curry Jr., usually called Aquababy,
was born in Aquaman #23.
In the 1960s Aquaman was breaking new ground
just by settling down and starting a family.
Of course he was also one of the only superheroes
who ruled his own kingdom.
Aquaman had always stood apart from other
heroes due to the aquatic nature of his adventures,
so it made sense for his stories to evolve
along their own path instead of following
the usual superhero tropes.
But by the 1970s, Aquaman's idyllic undersea
life would be coming to an end.
In Adventure Comics #452, Aquaman has a showdown
with his greatest villain, Black Manta, who
has kidnapped Aquababy and put him in a slow-moving
death trap.
That baby's a goner unless Aquaman and Aqualad
fight to the death.
"Black Manta!
That's not very neighborly!"
It's fairly standard supervillain fare and
it seems like Aquaman will get everyone out
alive like usual.
Unfortunately, it doesn't go that way this
time.
Aquaman disrupts Black Manta's plans, but
it's too late.
Arthur Curry Jr. is already gone when they
get him out of the suffocating bubble.
Ever since Aquaman's son died, his adventures
have taken on a darker tone, and his character
has had a more brooding attitude.
Give him a hand
Aquaman would be reimagined again in the 1990s.
He had already grown long hair and a beard,
and was soon one hand lighter after a villain
shoved him into a pool of carnivorous fish
that were conveniently immune to Aquaman's
telepathy.
He replaced his hand with the hooked end of
a harpoon and soon abandoned his famous orange
shirt, spending the next few years in a gray
armored half shirt and gray and green pants.
By 2003, the aesthetic of '90s Arthur Curry
already felt tied to that decade, and it was
time to move on.
A new creative team finally gave the hero
a shave and haircut, as well as a new left
hand.
This hand was made of water, created by the
magic of the Lady of the Lake a magical being
better known for helping out a different King
Arthur.
Back to basics
One of Aquaman's better known incarnations
was as a regular guest star on Batman: The
Brave and the Bold.
Voiced by John DiMaggio, this version of Arthur
Curry is bombastic, loud, and brash.
He's supremely confident in his abilities
as a hero and adventurer, and not shy about
sharing his confidence.
Unlike other versions of Aquaman, who were
often moody and bitter, Brave and the Bold's
Aquaman is endlessly upbeat and fun.
Interestingly, the Aquaman of the 2017 Justice
League film, played by Jason Momoa, has a
bit of Brave and the Bold Aquaman to him.
He's a more serious character, but he also
has the brash confidence and daredevil attitude
that made his animated counterpart such a
success.
Mixing the masculine charisma of Jason Momoa
with the classic outsider perspective Aquaman
has always had turned out to be a smash success,
and the character was a standout in Justice
League.
We'll have to see if the upcoming solo Aquaman
movie will manage to continue the character's
watery winning streak.